der große schlagzeiler heute steht die
Ampel vor dem Aus der so geht's auf
jeden Fall nicht weiter das sagt FDP
Vize Wolfgang Kubicki ihm reichts immer
neue Forderungen von Rot-Grün immer mehr
Kröten schlucken das hat er heute bei
uns im Studio gesagt schauen wir rein
und was mich besonders nervt meine
Partei übrigens auch jeden Tag haben wir
Diskussion über Steuererhöhungen und
Abgaben besondere Art Frau esken kann
sich ja gar nicht mehr einholen von
lauter Freude und vor allen Dingen
müssen wir dokumentieren auf den Vertrag
den wir geschlossen haben kann man sich
verlassen wer das in Frage gestellt SPD
oder grüne der stellt diese Koalition in
frage ich muss nicht mein
parteivorsitzen erklären was Sache ist
das weiß er selbst ich muss mein
koalitionswagen erklären dass diese von
uns ein Ende haben muss oder wir haben
einen fundamentales Problem bei der
Fortsetzung
fundamentale Probleme bei der
Fortsetzung Kubicki ist koalitions knall
könnte man sagen Herr Bruder sie haben
zugehört ist das jetzt der Anfang vom
Ende der Koalition nein das glaube ich
nicht die wollen durchhalten das sind
Droge werden das ist Action in den
Kulissen wobei ich meine er könnte schon
sagen lieber nicht regierender
schlechteregieren aber so weit gilt ganz
genau das Gegenüber schlechter regieren
als gut reagieren hauptsache man ist
dabei es ist ja kein Zufall ist
wahrscheinlich das olympische Motto
hauptsache man macht mit nicht und die
Ergebnisse
heute ist es Sensation morgen ist ein
Schall und Rauch ja sehen Sie das auch
so Herrer es gibt so viele Themen Atom
Bürgergeld die Steuern man trennen sie
sich wir treffen uns nicht nein wir
machen ja einen guten Job das ist wir
wissen das bürgerliche Korrektiv in
einer überwiegenden Regierung es muss
man alle mal immer bedenken dass wir
eben nicht links sind und natürlich gibt
es Kompromisse die gemacht werden müssen
ich finde Deutschland kein froh sein
dass wir dabei sind was ist denn die
Alternative ist da gibt es keine so
richtige Alternative momentan also
müssen wir das durchziehen und ich
verstehe Kubik hier auch in dem Sinne
genauso dass wir uns alle am Riemen
reißen müssen das ist seine Aufforderung
und das stimmt auch tatsächlich ja es
gibt keine Alternative wäre ja noch
möglich
finden Sie das gut also nachdem wir
nachdem wir ja aber nachdem wir aber
nachdem wir die Großen Koalition ja
wirklich erlebt haben lange ich fand
nicht dass das Deutschland nach vorne
gebracht hat aber das ist ja auch ein
Thema wo wir gleich reden werden
im einzelnen drauf dennoch muss man
sagen es gibt so viele Themen bei denen
sie nicht zusammenpassen mit vor allem
den Grünen wenn Sie das Hören Frau
Neigel das ist doch eigentlich hat man
halt so viele Themen ich habe das gerade
einmal aufgezählt dann passt einfach
nicht zusammen in der Beziehung als Paar
da würde man beispielsweise sagen also
wir mussten sofort sich trennen wie
wirkt das dann aussieht ja dann wie so
eine toxische Beziehung
gut jetzt kann man das nicht vergleichen
mit einer Bundesregierung aber es ist
schon so dass sich da zwei Parteien
gegenüberstehen insbesondere die Grünen
und die FDP die sehr sehr konträr denken
also die die FDP sagt sie wäre eine
freiheitlich denkende Partei die Grünen
zeigen sich im Moment aus meiner Sicht
eher ideologisch und es sind schon
Kontroverse Sichtweisen und Denkweisen
wie man ein Land regiert bei dem ich
denke das kann eigentlich nicht gehen
was glauben Sie warum bleiben die dann
zusammen es ist wie so ein Kleber an der
Macht kleben naja glauben heißt nicht
wissen aber ich vermute mal dass es
natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit ist für
die FDP an der Regierung zu sein und an
der Macht aber es ist manchmal auch ganz
klug zurückzutreten von zum Beispiel
einer Regierung wenn man sagt es geht
nicht man ist zu weit auseinander und
man geht wieder zurück in die Opposition
es kann durchaus auch sehr glaubwürdig
sein aber wir haben uns ja ganz gut
durchgesetzt ne also in vielen Bereichen
die Landtagswahl ja ja
warte mal wir haben ja noch wir haben
jetzt ja diese sehr merkwürdige Berlin
war die jetzt noch kommt dann haben wir
die Bremen Wahl die kommen dann gucken
wir mal wie sich das bis dahin
entwickelt hat ich glaube dass die
Grünen von den Umfrage werden ja auch
zurückgefallen sind jetzt so gut so die
CDU hat gewonnen die Union hat gewonnen
das stimmt bei den Umfragewerten aber
mal ganz ehrlich noch mal wir haben
keine Alternativen und es wird auch
keine Neuwahlen es wird keine Neuwahlen
geben in der jetzigen Situation da wird
Steinmeier nie Zustimmung
es gibt immer ja immer eine
Alternativen
nein das ist glaube ich wir haben uns
glaube ich ganz gut arrangiert damit
dass wir uns die kleine U-Boote an
vielen Stellen durchsetzen können
funktioniert
ja hat er auch recht man fühlt sich
manchmal wie beim Kröten Essen das
stimmt auch aber das geht den anderen
genauso das ist ja nicht nur die Sache
nicht besser
mit der Ehe zu vergleichen ist schon
sehr schwierig aus dem gibt's
schwierig es ist nicht also ich finde es
gut dass wir uns streiten weil wir
tatsächlich wirklich aus völlig
verschiedenen Ecken kommen und sie haben
völlig recht mit der SPD kann man in
bestimmten Bereichen also gerade im
Wirtschaftsbereich sehr gut zusammen
aber arbeiten bei den Grünen jetzt eher
dann um Bürgerrechte da haben wir
gewisse nehmen zueinander aber ansonsten
klar und nicht nur wir streiten uns mit
alle streiten sich untereinander aber
das ist doch toll also der Diskurse
dabei steht für am meisten zu einer
besseren Lösung als wenn wir uns alle
einig werden immer
großen Koalition nicht geklappt hat
nicht weil der großen
Koalitionäre ist jetzt Kanzler es gibt
schon eine gewisse Kontinuität in der
deutschen vielleicht aber auch einfach
an dem schlechten Spitzenkandidaten der
Union sie haben immer eine
ausredet ich mag den aber ja
so stark auf dem Tisch haut wie groß ist
denn das in der FDP oder ist es jetzt
einfach seine einzelung es gibt auch
schon im Lager wir haben das ist schon
groß aber es ist nicht die Mehrheit
aber ein großes Lager und wie gehen Sie
damit um das ist ja normal in der Partei
das ist verschiedene Strömungen gibt und
man dann die ausdiskutiert das hat das
sehr gut funktioniert wie wird das auf
Sie Herr Windisch sie hören Politiker
darüber sprechen ja Streit ist normal
ist das für sie etwas dass sie mit
Befremden aufnehmen oder können Sie das
Nachvollziehen ich kann das durchaus
nachvollziehen dass man sich da nicht
ganz einig ist aber dazu werde ich mich
jetzt nicht so ganz weiter äußern ich
halte mich da eher zurück was das angeht
ist nicht mein Fachgebiet dennoch wir
haben ja ganz viele Probleme jetzt die
Menschen haben Angst vor der
Arbeitslosigkeit die Energiepreise die
schießen in die Höhe und jetzt haben wir
eine Koalition die so viele Punkte hat
an denen man sich nicht einig ist
welches Bild schafft man da oder das
finden Sie im Prinzip ist es schon
richtig dass man sich streitet wie sagt
man das in ihrem Milieu da bin ich ganz
bei Ihnen hahaha
[Gelächter]
Komfortzone genau aber wissen Sie wenn
Sie noch mal ich muss darauf
zurückkommen wir sagen es gibt keine
Alternative das ist Merkels Philosophie
das Scheitern natürlich gibt es
alternativ skandinavische Modelle was
Minderheiten Regierungen gibt die sich
jeweils die Mehrheiten zusammen suchen
müssen es gibt holländischer Modelle es
gibt ganz viele andere Wege es zu machen
nur wenn man sozusagen an der Macht
klebt um an der Macht zu kleben ich
glaube das schädigt auf die Dauer die
Fantasie sehe ich genau so sagen
es gab noch nie Minderheitsregierung in
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland das hat
seinen Grund das ist ja ein bisschen
anders als in Dänemark wissen sie das
ist wie meine Lehre ich meine er hat
eine Wage Erinnerung ja ich weiß wir
haben das immer so gemacht ja ist
richtig
zu versuchen
also
Fußballweltmeisterschaft in Katar das
ist echt mal was ich überlegen Sie mal
was wir alles schon gutes gemacht haben
sie haben gesagt die Energiepreise
steigen jetzt sondern dass das stimmt
weiterhin in der Regierung bleiben sie
wollen weiter Sachpolitik betreiben